Це Юлія Микитенко….
А це Марія Щанкіна. Дві українські жінки.
Кияни могли випадково побачити Юлію, наприклад, поспішаючи додому в метро,
а Марію - під час прогулянки в столичному зоопарку.
Хтось навіть міг зустрітися з ними поглядом і не зрозуміти, що думками вони... на війні.
Захисниці Юлія і Марія належать до понад 13 тисяч жінок в Україні, які отримали бойовий досвід на Сході України.
Марія навчала десантників тактичної медицини і евакуйовувала поранених в Торецьку.
Юлія спочатку працювала діловодом-бухгалтером, а потім керувала розвід-взводом на Світлодарській дузі.
Повернення до мирного життя, якому передувала загибель на фронті її чоловіка, стало для Юлії викликом.
Коли я ходила по місту, я уявляла, як будуть виглядати ті чи інші будинки, якщо у них влучить снаряд.
Це не дуже прикольні відчуття. Мене це трошки дратувало, що коли я проходила по вулиці і проходила повз людей, то для них все було нормально.
Зараз я розумію, що це добре, бо це заради чого ми там знаходилися, і зараз стоять військові,
щоби люди могли собі спокійно собі жити, але тоді у мене це викликало агресію.
Повністю обривати зв'язки з армією Юлія не хотіла.
Досвід, здобутий на війні, ще два роки передавала своїм вихованкам - першому в історії взводу дівчат у Київському військовому ліцеї імені Івана Богуна.
І навіть тепер, після звільнення, працює в громадській організації, яка долає гендерні стереотипи в армії.
Брак рівноправ'я між чоловіками і жінками в українській армії певною мірою відчула на собі Марія.
Жінка має дві освіти - медичну і ветиринарну.
Коли почалася війна і на фронті бракувало медиків, вона не змогла далі спокійно працювати у столичній ветлікарні.
Марія відслужила у Збройних силах два контракти. Під час першого вчила десантників тактичної медицини.
І хоча її курси проходили навіть офіцери Генштабу, офіційно вона вважалася лише медсестрою лазарету.
Адже тодішній устав не дозволяв довірити посаду інструктора в елітних десантних військах жінці.
При цьому сама вона ніколи не вимагала до себе особливого ставлення.
Я ніколи не відокремлювала себе, що я дівчинка. Я така сама військовослужбовиця, як і хлопці.
Я ніколи не робила для себе поблажки, через це. Треба нести тяжкий рюкзак - я несу або щось важке зробити "хлопці поможіть" - ні, самі!
І все ж, повертатися в армію Марія більше не хоче.
Натомість присвячує себе улюбленій професії - працює ветлікарем у Київському зоопарку.
Принаймні російсько-українська війна дещо прискорила реформування армії і в гендерних питаннях.
Так, з 2016 року Міністерство оборони розширило перелік посад, які можуть обіймати жінки.
Водночас жінки і надалі ходять не в усі наряди, часто не мають окремих вбиралень чи душових,
а на полігонах чи в зоні конфлікту спальні місця ділять із колегами-чоловіками,
розповідає радниця Головнокомандувача Збройних сил з гендерних питань.
З такими реаліями українського війська щоденно стикаються 32 тисячі жінок.
Дуже багато змін було зроблено в законодавстві, але багато чого ще не зроблено.
Наприклад, ми сьогодні за наказом міністра оборони відраховуємо вагітних курсанток.
З тим, щоби вона повертала ті кошти, які були витрачені на її навчання. Да, на жаль.
Така норма досі існує, і наше завдання, якомога скоріше прибрати цю норму.
Не завжди усвідомленою і далеко не вирішеною проблемою залишаються і випадки сексуальних домагань серед військових.
Юлія Микитенко намагається зарадити, працюючи над спеціальним чат-ботом, куди військові (і хлопці, і дівчата)
зможуть анонімно заявляти про сексуальне насильство чи домагання.
Військовослужбовці це люди, і вони мають право відстоювати свої особисті кордони.
Безпосередньо з сексуальними домаганнями - ні, але з такими речами як "а давай ти как то атблагадаріш", натякаючи на якісь сексуальні речі, таке було.
Я зазвичай не звертала на це увагу, але ти себе в такі моменти перестаєш відчувати людиною.
Марія вважає, що в армії, як і, наприклад, у медицині, немає жінок і чоловіків. Мовляв, на війні всі - в першу чергу, воїни.
Я ніколи не відчувала відсутності цієї інфраструктури.
Я ходила завжди в спільний туалет з хлопцями, ні, я, звичайно, казала: стоять тут на стрьомі, а я сходжу.
Не питання! Бронижилет для жінок - ну це смішно!
Зрештою, ворожі снаряди теж не розрізняють, хто сидить в окопах української армії: дівчата чи хлопці, кажуть ветеранки.
Тож головний біль, забої внутрішніх органів, інколи важкий посттравматичний синдром - це те,
з чим щодня живуть не лише захисники, а й захисниці, які повертаються в мирні українські міста і села з фронту.